[Music]
you guys know i i love bringing very
very bright and happy news to the table
yes another murder
no no this isn't as bad as regular human
is it a rape like your usual jesus
christ you're not usually don't be
bringing jesus into this all right not
here when a church blew up again
classic anthony anthony was bringing the
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] let's bring out the
blowing up churches that sounds tricia's
shaking here we go
um
so there were some tourists
tourists tourists tourists
tourists there were some cheerists
that were dragged away and eaten by
bears after a helicopter went down in a
crash holy [ __ ] or soya has been deduced
by the authorities oh yeah bears will
get you right the bodies of three
tourists who died in a helicopter crash
in russia oh [ __ ] met this gruesome fate
as they were reportedly dragged away and
eaten by bears
they were alive then and then they
survived the crash and then
to add drama to the story absolutely so
they were alive one guy was like my leg
my leg was like no no eat me eat me stay
alive whatever ooh blood that's what he
said he said
he said blood because if you you crash
right
you're like oh
[ __ ] we made it oh thank god the [ __ ]
better car
no
you can't get the seat
some people wouldn't call that comedy
it's like a fresh prince episode that's
almost like that
so a 25 year old former biathlete igor
malinowski was piloting a high
helicopter
in the kamchatka peninsula in far east
siberia when the vehicle crashed also
board was 39 year old mobile phone
company executive sergey kolonasi
kolesniak
a businesswoman in her mid-30s who
organized the trip to the popular
tourist destination the crash occurred
on july 16th with the trip going wrong
when bad weather cut off contact uh to
the helicopter where is believed to have
caught fire and then crashed
damn helicopters man no restaurant you
guys you guys all been on helicopters
nope yeah i want to try it is it nice i
mean it's yeah it's pretty cool it's
pretty fun is it loud yeah yeah you got
but you have like things on also you can
only hear other people i'm that idiot
though who like asks the pilot to be
like hey can you do any tricks in this
and then they always do it what do they
do put it upside down they don't go
fully upside down but they they will do
like you know like high like just dives
and stuff they'll go like this
oh judo because i was in there and i
asked them oh i didn't do that yeah that
was the part of the story
because i thought you said you didn't go
and then uh ryan went i did go okay
okay
why don't you listening to me man he's
calling out your [ __ ] anthony yeah
he's calling you dude i got photos man
show right now he doesn't believe show
me where i got photo receipts i did it
in seattle
and then i did it in rio
yeah yeah we're talking about ryan's
experiences rio in brazil so i didn't
have to walk up to the uh christ the
redeemer because i didn't want to walk
do you think you're better because you
you went to rio
i think i'm better because i was in a
helicopter all right and i made it have
you ridden a helicopter
[Laughter]
yeah he's never been close to a
helicopter we're gonna get you one now
man i we gotta ride a helicopter dude we
can't beat damn we could go to
battlefield vegas and shoot targets out
of a helicopter really out of a
helicopter that's cool no no no no no
while you're flying you can shoot
how the [ __ ] do they legalize that they
just should do it on the [ __ ] one
wait how much is it to fly a helicopter
i don't know how much the price but we
could do it we should do it you could
also
rent a tank there and run over cars yeah
that's wild it's like a thousand bucks
or something
yeah that's pretty cheap for what i know
right yeah but then the car is not new
so that's kind of lame yeah it's already
a beat-up car specifically you're like
can we get new cars to run over please
you know what helicopter rides in in la
like the the just the fun ones are
pretty cheap too like 100 100 something
bucks oh yeah in uh vegas too that's
cheaper than
it's true yeah it's cheaper than an uber
from the airport yeah bro but it is
pretty cool because like when they go
over uh l.a but like specifically la you
get to see all these like pockets that
normally you don't have access to drive
to so you're like what the [ __ ] is that
like when we were up there there was
just like somewhere in the mountains
there was this gigantic ass mansion that
like had a long windy road that was like
miles and miles long it was just their
mansion yeah yeah and i was like who the
[ __ ] lives there i thought it was like
some famous person and the guy goes
that's the house of the dude that uh
created herbalife no way
and it's just like chilling in this like
like it's like in a basin like do you
have the mountain and then it goes in
and his house is like in the middle of
the basin we need to start a pyramid
scam yeah dude
we need to do a pyramid scheme yeah
let's do something yeah i'm gonna we'll
talk we'll check maybe some like sub
like supplements supplements are easy
like barbell brigade does i'm down to
make that a pyramid scam yeah
existing good company you want to start
a business yeah you give me a thousand
bucks i'm in and you're saying no no no
no
no
franchise say less i'll do it that's how
it starts and all you got to do is bring
in 10 more people to sell this
supplement protein i know four guys
right here did any of you guys i'll join
were any of you ever victims of a
pyramid scheme a thousand percent i was
a victim and a and a predator what do
you mean two by two you did two original
two by two
guess how much i made how much five
hundred dollars
what did you spend to make that five
hundred it was like five hundred dollars
i feel like it was like a hundred bucks
to join oh [ __ ] well i think i i
recruited like five five people or
something like that but that means
you're saying you got like five people
to give one hundred dollars exactly too
doesn't it like buildings i forgot what
it was man but i was 18 years old and it
was my first time thinking i was a
salesman and i went to chinatown to get
a suit
um that's lit you're a [ __ ] salesman
went to chinatown no because my buddy
was like dude
this is a job interview man you gotta
look good for the part and i'm like
really i don't even have a suit and he
goes i'll hook you up we're gonna go to
chinatown and i'm like dude a suit is so
expensive he goes nah i got you man it's
[ __ ] you if it if you get at
chinatown it's like 60 bucks for the
whole set or something like that yeah
right
like at the time it was probably like
under 50 right and you bargained and
[ __ ] and you're like nah i want it for
48 don't be like nah you're gonna
[ __ ] buy for 50 and you're like nah
man i'm gonna leave and they're like no
come back because you're my friend i'll
give it to you for 47. or some [ __ ] like
that you know they always do that
because you're my friends yeah because
you're my friend i'll give you a deal
tell your friends to come here okay yeah
they always do that same [ __ ] tactic
so i got the suit and i was like dude
i'm [ __ ] nervous man i'm [ __ ]
having a job interview we go to
starbucks and [ __ ] and then this whole
time like this guy's like motivational
speaking to me and all this and i'm like
what kind of [ __ ] job is this you
gotta pay to work all right [ __ ] it
let's do it and then later um i was like
i think this is one of those scams and
he goes
well what in life is not a pyramid
it's a good response man thousands come
back
i don't know what trapezoid he's like
he's like he just wrote it out and he
goes all right in a company you got your
ceo at the top you got all these workers
management you have the people on the
bottom that's a pyramid and i'm all like
you got me there this guy's good i'm 18
years old and i don't have a rebuttal
and i was like but
tell me how to [ __ ] sell and and he
goes all right i'll teach you how to
sell and that's it he's like your family
they trust you
believe anything you say so two by
2.2.net was basically the socal asians
uh late 90s introduction to fraudulent
entrepreneurship aka the only type of
entrepreneurship yeah but you would see
lambos with two by two stickers like
ferrari driving around 2x2 stickers on
it and then we sold internet service
we sold
calling cars right
url web space stuff
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
try to sell these things i think my
uncle bought like a like a dot like a
dial up service thingy and then um got
some friends recruited
and um that was it man but you would
always hear about like the [ __ ]
conferences like sales companies they
were sick bro like it would be like
parties right because you'd only get
people rallied they'd be like throwing
out [ __ ] armani or gucci belts and
stuff like that to get people just like
there's so many cool asians involved in
it yeah at the time it was like so
visible dude they you could even see
there's videos right now on youtube you
[ __ ] put in like two by two right and
all this you'll see that they recorded
the whole event and there they'll be
like montages and [ __ ] documentaries
that they made and it's [ __ ] sick
like they'll be rolling up in all their
lambos and [ __ ] with the big ass like
sticker 2x2.net like on the side of
their [ __ ] lamborghini and all that
and then like everyone's waiting for
them to come and then the whole thing is
like a big show everyone's like [ __ ]
throwing like glow sticks in the air
it's a party and if you're 18 [ __ ]
even people in their 40s this is like
this is business damn this is thai
they still do that [ __ ] to this day i
mean yeah there's always a sucker every
year right like they're always doing
these crazy things but i didn't know i
was doing like something bad like i
didn't know it was like fraudulent i
just thought like oh this is a new way
to do business wow that's so it was it
was it's just like a step up from cutco
yeah
it was cooler than coco yeah the knife
selling one amway
life [ __ ] my sister's ex-boyfriend
was doing cocoa and then like in my
parents dry cleaners i'll never forget i
was [ __ ] young right but he had these
really sharp not sharp knives and then
so i was trying to test him out and i
cut my [ __ ] finger and into the nail
you know when you're like [ __ ] it
goes through a nail right [ __ ] around
with it yeah i was just trying to like
cut stuff and then i like cut it and i
pulled down i was like oh and then like
three seconds later the blood finally
starts to come out and i'll start like
panicking because i'm like a kid and i
start doing pale and [ __ ] like that
because there's a lot of blood started
[ __ ] gushing out that's a sick ass
advertisement yeah that's
the sale super super sharp but then like
after that like since then my nail
hasn't really grown back like in the
nice round like i have like one flatter
side cut
since i was a kid yeah
it's a pretty good knife i should have
bought it i think i was just out of the
sale
i learned a lot about sales though after
that it's pretty uh interesting man
but at the same time [ __ ] pyramid scams
man don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] if you
guys want to learn about sales and you
want to learn how to sell
join a parent on a pyramid scam it's
just for that just just for the lesson
but also
you don't have to pay money to make
money for other people
that's the stupidest [ __ ] ever you have
to pay [ __ ] money so you can sell a
product for them yeah crazy is there a
hot pyramid scheme like right now that
everybody's kind of suckering into nfts
is it do you think so i think a lot of
uh well a lot of them are being called
not just entities but even the crypto
space in general a lot of them are just
being called like ponzi's because of the
transfer of money so not pyramid and in
the same structural like you pay to join
and then you do xyz to get others but in
a more indirect and loose concept it's
like you
buy into a crypto price at a certain
level then you start marketing it to
other people you're like this is the
next hot project other people buy in but
like where does that wealth transfer go
right you know what i mean the second
like somebody else comes in is the
second the price can appreciate
depending so they every time you
convince someone else to buy it they're
paying a higher price than you did and
then if you convince the other person
not even a higher price
so it's like a little bit more of like
an argument it's like isn't everything a
ponzi because there's no like direct
product that's like being interchanged
between people's hands or like you're
not buying into like a service or like
this this thing that you're saying this
is what i get for it
but it you know conceptual i think the
actual definition of ponzi is like you
pay me right as an investment and i go
oh you you know what this investment is
doing well then you pay me this yeah you
give me my rewards him
the money that you gave me that's why
it's like a loose argument of the ponzi
because in essence it's like people are
arguing right even on like senate floors
it's like hey uh i bought bitcoin at
this price when you buy it at this next
price and i sell it it's like it's your
money that i'm earning like the profit
comes from other people you know what i
mean not from a product so you got to
start the business yeah i think that is
it i think the idea that like if bitcoin
yeah bitcoin isn't like uh in the
example if bitcoin isn't accepted as
currency around the world then it's just
this
existing thing that people transfer well
through so people who buy in other
people cash out and there's no product
is the argument but there's something
called the speculative market that just
does the same [ __ ] so
but yeah you got to start the ponzi
start a ponzi and you're good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you